[Music]
well you've probably already received
your CCSD schools have begun sending out
reminder vaccination requirements to
parents for their children to be able to
attend school in the fall
during the early days of the covid-19
pandemic when families stayed home and
Health Care Facilities were closed many
children missed their routine
immunizations including the MMR vaccine
and some still may not have gotten all
their recommended shots Dr Kerry wije
singha of Siena pediatrics in Henderson
has started to see an uptick in
vaccination Administration again over
the past year but she says there have
been anti-vaccination groups and their
influence has impacted the overall
vaccination rates due to this scenario
certain groups of children are now at
high risk of preventable diseases
earlier this year there was a huge
measles outbreak in Ohio spread among
children who were not fully vaccinated
more than a third of those kids had to
be hospitalized measles is a very
contagious disease Health experts say
you need to maintain a high vaccination
coverage to keep it from spreading Dr
Joseph Eiser retired as Chief Health
officer for the Southern Nevada Health
District in 2020 he is now representing
the American College of preventative
citizen with the following advice
vaccines are the safest way far safer
than getting any of the diseases we've
talked about measles mumps in particular
uh polio but other diseases as well it's
much safer than getting the disease
itself and it will prevent illness and
death
we do have a link posted on our website
with the complete guide of vaccinations
required at CCSD head to 8newsnow.com